I was watching david dobrik Slyke most
recent vlog today yeah they go into this
oh they go into this shop in 69 each now
they go into like a plastic surgeon's
office okay because you know Jonah yeah
he wants to get his penis and large I
can talk about this but go ahead okay
you can no no no no I have something
peripheral okay okay okay so they're
sitting there and they're like getting
like I I I was weird man I don't know if
it was serious or not I don't know if
he's actually going through with it or
what but like the nurse comes in or like
one of the doctors or something and
she's like basically like analyzing him
and he like everyone's in the room and
he just [ __ ] takes off his [ __ ] and
he's like he's like real real talk like
how small is my dick have you ever seen
anything smaller and she was like she
was like well I've seen one that's like
the same size as yours he's like we've
never seen any dicks that are smaller
and she's and she was like she was like
no he's like so I'm the smallest dick
that you've seen oh how did I ever stood
ends and I'm like hey well I don't what
do I think of that that's gotta be fake
man you think so that's some script
that's such an easy joke to get by I can
you just say that it's the smallest one
you've ever seen yeah but also like is
he going
is he getting his dick enlarged I would
even go there alright so what I was
gonna say yeah is I did a little react
video on twitch to some BBC doc these
guys getting penis fillers is that what
it is you just they were talking about
inject the doctor was like yeah
basically take fat cells from certain
areas of your body and we inject them
into your dick yeah I mean there's that
like okay so in this one it was like
silicone okay it was like a cosmetic
thing okay and it's actually one of my
twitch emotes is the diagram of a penis
look how it works okay cuz it looks like
a face okay just like shocked like so
yeah and these dudes I mean not just in
the doc like people get and it's like
the equivalent to lip fillers yeah so it
fattens it up what was funny was and you
gotta keep getting him though yeah you
have to keep going back in
so it's like even if I thought he was
gonna go through then do it it's like
it's not a big deal it's like it wears
away and you have to go back for more
but what's funny was in the video I
watched this dude goes there with his
girl and his girl is like um I'm just
concerned it's not gonna fit okay so
like this dude I was like oh he's double
dipping he's already he's already good
yeah was oh so he was already like big
or like decent yeah yeah and he's just
because like and what I laughed at in
the video is like the two guys one of
them his smile is like kind of we can
dry like like like just please put it
like he needs it yeah and the other dude
is like like his eyes are like lit up
he's like looks electric get this cuz
he's like he's like just outside porn
[ __ ] and he's like I can get there
that's ridiculous
you don't need it you probably stands in
the mirror like alright look at these
bro it's like a salmon yeah dude so oh
so he doesn't go through with it I don't
I don't know it just ended I don't know
I mean maybe he did man it's crazy
though dude that dudes shameless man
yeah just a [ __ ] drop trou like that
in front of everyone be like so do I
have the smallest dick in the world or
what I I mean act like damn I commend
the confidence this is me too that's
what I'm saying that's jackass level
confidence seriously yeah it really is
man it really is some Eric Andre [ __ ] we
said Eric Andre you know posed naked on
Instagram I think I googled it after I
watched the hot ones episode I mean like
they were talking about him posting like
full frontal nudity house and I was kind
of like I'm gonna see how big his
biggest dick is I mean I think I was
following him at the time and you saw
I'm just like whoa yeah so funny did you
post that shared Instagram it's so
[ __ ] funny full frontal nudity it's
just like there's like the Lighting's
all shitty too like because every I
think that's the way to get attention on
Instagram now is not to have like a
high-res phone
gotta be a piece of [ __ ] photo yeah yeah
cuz you're like oh [ __ ] is just oh
that's a day I mean yeah when you when
he said that I was like I gotta see what
this fools dick looks like I gotta see
it I've been looking at some gay [ __ ] on
Instagram dude I'm [ __ ] gay [ __ ]
[ __ ] gay I mean like it's not like I
mean this is this is some this is by
[ __ ] they say this is not this gage I
couldn't believe this though dude what
is it play right into the mic oh my god
that's hilarious holy [ __ ] believe it
rap forward man that's crazy that's a
[ __ ] man it's just I was looking at
this feeling like ya do we're gonna
become Rome
all that's left is like everyone's gonna
go naked you're gonna get shamed into
liking everything yeah yeah what you
mean you don't go both ways yeah you
straight or something yeah what three
little straight boy straight a little
bit kiss me right now
what now that's just it's like a oh oh
oh so you you weird you wait no no no
you strange no I'm not straight kiss me
right now then use me on the lips Tom
Brady come on I just I kind of don't
that's crazy what's the name of that guy
I don't know it's just like I don't even
know how I end up down these rabbit
holes on Instagram just like what's the
weirdest [ __ ] I can find it
it doesn't say man-made what do you say
I still want the [ __ ] in your butt man
and your butt dude everyone kind of
horse everyone listen to that like okay
kind of wait well if you want you want
my wet bars bars well that is a yeah
that's the new face a rap dude by openly
by [ __ ] not like the thug like kind of
sexually ambiguous not like young thug
not like non-smoking penises yeah no I
just like that because then you're kind
of like well is it what is he talking
about
no it's on a nose like no I'm sucking
dick and eating box and eating box just
gets on stage y'all sucking everybody
off well we're all nothing tonight Oh
kissing every dude tonight yeah that's
not a flag